dan can you kind of peel back the layer
for us can you take us through like the
life of a submission like suppose I'm
submitting my film whether I do it
what is it through film freeway or if I
actually mail it in what happens to that
film yeah well we'll take a quick story
for today I picked up a DVD and in our
mailbox today was the only one so far
for this whole year so this is a good a
DVD is here like I was surprised that I
was surprised to get it to be honest it
used to be a time where was all DVDs and
we had it just the process of mailing
DVDs and our mail was piled it was
insane and now it's nice and clean
all streaming the one DVD is like well
is a DVD here it's like an anomaly it's
like it's funny the times have changed
you know but but yeah we so for us the
majority of our submissions come through
film freeway now obviously we have other
platforms we're on we are on still
without a box although yes without a
boxes as everyone now knows the next
October they're they're closing up shop
so that box is now done or will be
defunct at that time so we are still on
without a box and then other platforms a
real port fest home click-click for
festivals so these other platforms there
a lot of those International Film
Festival Life all all these are either
Australia Germany Spain different
countries that have their platforms as
well we're on essentially many of the
platforms for submission you know
process but film freeway is our main you
know top one and our main one that most
people submit through so you know say
for instance a foam freeway so they send
emails every time some of the platforms
and emails when submission comes in so
man box are gonna email come in and see
these - films are submitting as they
come in so okay look this this is a film
this just came in I'll take a look and
then I go log in and then I devote a
certain time of the day to watching a
sphere amount of films each day and then
from there I'm just gonna go through
that process of watching films that are
coming in and you know rate them we do 1
through 10 system so that's how we judge
our stuff is 1 through 10 along with of
course notes to go with that and flags
flags meaning you know green means this
blue means this there's different inside
stuff we designate to what a flag with
me you know orange might mean this and
there's different colors we have that we
can designate to what that may might
mean for our judges it for us
okay so I go back and look I can say oh
how many of these are green this is what
green mean green means second-round or
you know I'm just throwing that out
there it's not necessarily that but you
know so there's a different process with
how we do the flags but the main thing
is still of course the scoring of a film
scores low it's you know not likely to
get a second look the film scores high
it's going to have a chance to get a
second look and then go on to a second
round of viewing after all the films are
watched so you know that score is a very
very critical part of the process but
yeah it simply put I looked through the
films I watch a certain amount each day
whether it's sometimes five sometimes
just 10 to 20 sometimes even more and
I'm just looking through the films
watching them and scoring them and
putting my notes and saving them film
freeways great because I can save them
other judges that go in there or other
people like Theo and myself and Nicole
we can see each other scores notes I can
assign the film's to other judges or to
them and so they can see hey if I send
something to that maybe I'll really like
it and wanted to see it so hey Theo
check this one out and put a note and so
we can come in communicate that way and
yeah so that's the film for your process
it's similar in some other platforms but
not exactly the same with how they use
their system for judging we have a
separate document that we create
spreadsheet with all of the film's so we
can score and put notes in there that
way we can always make sure there's a
place that we have them so we know that
we watched it because again all these
platforms are different without a boxes
system of how they do notes and scoring
isn't the same as freeway and fest home
is different so on and so forth they're
not all the same as far as how they're
set up for scoring so we use those
master documents to make sure we keep
track all the films and all the scores
so when we go in there we can you know
make sure that we can see it or if I
want to see a film and and I double
check hey look they already saw this and
he gave this a score and this is this
judge saw this and gave this score and
there's their notes and and then that
kind of thing so basically the score are
the notes you know are a big part of it
obviously and the beauty of some free
ways you could save it there and you
know have it ready to go and anyone can
view it if they have access to view and
so we can kind of share notes internally
that way where it's saved and lives on
the application in our backend when we
save the score on the notes so yeah so
that's the kind of a little look into
that process it's basically a two full
thing it's using the systems that are in
place like fest home film freeway
without a box all that and to our best
as far as scoring and saving notes
so it's always living there you can go
find it on the application but also
having our spreadsheet that we have a
master document where we import all the
submissions from all the different
platforms and things so we can always
double check and put our scores in there
and make sure we have another place that
we're not missing a score or missing
notes and where a film gets washed and
doesn't have a score notes so we always
have a place to kind of a backup to make
sure we have all the information we need
as far as scoring and all that they're
from different judges so of a film that
is going to make it into the actual
festival that's in August and every year
how many eyeballs have been on that that
film that actually makes it into the 400
that makes it to the festival um I mean
that's at least at least at that point
at least three people at least if even
maybe even sometimes more we have our
mean of course there's myself the own
accord sorry three of us right there so
generally for those films at that tier
that level if not two or three of us
have watched maybe not stay for instance
maybe at some point myself and Nicole
watch and until Theo about it and you
know we don't have to like approve each
other like I program the fest so if I'm
in the end reviewing all the stuff based
on the notes and then other judges and
we decided this film this film is
acceptance this is amazing the Zen we
talked about it it's in it I don't have
to have all three of us watch a film to
accept it it's going sense you know so
you can sort of bypass that so sometimes
maybe not all three of us have watch it
you know and I guess at that point would
matter it's accepted it's in so there's
still great so you know but yeah so it's
still at least two of the three of us
and then of course there's a review team
involved and so initially so if say
we've signed up certain films to the
review team and say hey you judge hey
you're gonna watch this is your batch of
films you're watching these you give me
your scores and notes and your thing and
do all that they're okay
they watch the films I go in and I'm
gonna review all their stuff okay these
films got these scores this is what has
a chance is when doesn't this one I want
to see what these are and there's
certain tier level of scores I'm gonna
be watch all those and then see you know
what's going on with those are those
going on in next round do I agree with
their score I think the score is poor
though I think their scores amazing do I
think they even scored two lowness is
even better than I expected and all even
added my even notes and they could
average and film free has a system where
averages to note two scores so one judge
a watches films they they give this an
eight eight and have their notes this is
why and they gave it a thumbs-up and
this is this okay
well I think this thing is actually
better I think this is a nine this is
incredible I'll put my notes in and my
thing and then also save that it
averages both scores together so now the
score will go to 8.5 just doing easy
math 9 8
you know averages out 8.5 now so now I
bump to score up a bit and I'll note
that this is a second round viewing and
I've watched us now for a second round
and this has a chance and whatever I'll
put my notes in there for that too
we're gonna come back to that film that
film is now sort of moved on the next
round and that's kind of how that
process works or the opposite could be
true judge walks watches it they give a
certain score i watch you know disagree
with the score this is even this isn't
it this is not gonna be something that's
gonna be acceptable for our standards
it's not gonna make the festival put a
certain score in note that and at that
point that's sort of it's got its second
viewing and it's now essentially going
to be rejected so if that makes sense so
it's kind of that's how that can go so
usually there's generally a lot of times
a to viewing process is our goal now
sometimes it doesn't happen because the
film's score so poorly you know that
amongst all the films and the amount of
films are submitted is that that low of
a score quality isn't there it's it's
not going to get a second viewing not
likely outside of a double check of like
myself or Theo or us checking double
checking the film's because sometimes
I've seen films were a review team
person gave something a one and it was
actually not a one it was actually a ten
because of the drastic each of the film
that the judge was actually very so I
guess it's just a offended by it
we thought it was actually incredible
and in the film accident get making the
festival so there was the opposite so
you have to double-check scores whether
it's even very low or very high it is to
make sure we're the the sort of head is
that of the reviewer so again talk about
the film for a festival and it fell
under we felt that our standards is what
we're looking for you know so now that
was a drastic example because the film
was a bit graphic in nature and ready
yeah I won't get into details on that
but it was but it was very interesting
fascinating film very good so but that's
that's part of the process you have to
double-check things because sometimes
you know we don't want things to follow
up through the cracks and it's it's not
easy it's not always possible I mean
there's so many films and and it's it's
blessing that's great but is it also
difficult but we do want to always sort
of stance
all of it because again you can find
those those films that I would have been
very disappointed if that film didn't
make the vestal we felt really strongly
about it and and about the filmmaker in
about the the actual movie so you know
that's why you got a double check films
and try to watch twice and I just watch
once and just let it fall by the wayside
but again it's not easy now not all
films can get that second viewing and
they're viewing at times but that's the
goal is to go to rounds and have films
watch more than once because also
there's how you feel when you watch the
film if you watched fifty films are you
tired or you're like I'm over this you
don't want to judge based on being
grumpy or not in the mood that's not
fair you want to make sure that has
another viewing say okay this looks
really good that's an interesting
elements I like the story but maybe it's
as slow-moving for my taste right now
but I'm also you know watch 40 movies or
something I'm tired that's not something
you want to judge on that's not fair you
want to make sure okay let's put this
aside you watch it a sign of another
just let them take a look and see if
they agree with your scores they like it
better than like a worse what are their
thoughts because again we our review
team of the people that are reviewing
that gone through the process and our
our folks we trust their word we trust
them that they're gonna obviously judge
in our in our sort of style and way so
yeah at that point we're comfortable
passing it on and seeing what they think
but that's a big thing it's like that's
not also judged based on you know just
mood of like how you know how I'm
feeling you know uh mad I had a bad day
you know I'm going to be harsh like
that's you know it's human nature you
have to try to fight against not being
impartial or in a bad place and just
like judging based on that just because
something's not maybe for you it's not
me that I'm not the person I'm not the
audience I'm just someone who should try
obviously judge basically I think is
fitting for the festival but I'm not the
audience does that make sense so it's
but it's that's also it you have to try
to humble yourself that way right it's
not normal way of watching something you
like some of your leg is great I hate
something you hate it you hate it
there's a personal preference of things
in life we all have preference but it's
not always about the preference it's
about what is right for the audience
what is deserving of a spot not based on
what you know you know whatever was
something I loved so much personally
just for me you know because it's not
about just me you know you does that
make sense
you